all right guys we are officially
back in business it is september 2nd
2021 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message and it is thursday
so we will be doing a reuben report
community q a you guys sent in a
whole
slew of questions a lot of off-the-grid
stuff a lot of what's it like to catch
up with the world stuff afghanistan
stuff covid stuff cuomo stuff a lot of
stuff and i'm prepared to talk about all
of it uh just real quick before we start
i am going to do one story on larry
elder because adam carolla yesterday
when he brought me back on the grid
showed me this absolutely
bananas bonkers headline from the los
angeles times about larry elder being a
white supremacist and the one thing that
i did do while i was off the grid all
month i did only one thing that was
related to any part of my public life or
politics or anything else was go to a
dinner
for larry elder there was a fundraising
dinner that i felt i should be at i was
invited to and i was a sort of connector
with a bunch of the people that were
there to help larry raise some funds and
make some connections here in california
and
it appears that i had dinner with a
black white supremacist so it's going to
be a bit of a maya culpa today which you
know since i've been back on the grid
for about 24 hours it seems like you
know that's how the internet works
you've got to have some sort of apology
or retraction or maya culpa within your
first 24 hours back on the grid and then
yeah i'm going to tell you guys all
about a little bit more about some of
the personal side of being off the grid
and i think as several of you have
pointed out quite nicely in some of the
comments uh yeah i'm feeling very
refreshed and very ready to fight and
ready to go
and all that stuff and unfortunately the
the country continues to burn which you
know i did announce the pre-sale of my
book the day before i left and maybe the
title don't burn this country it was a
little too on the nose maybe i kind of
nailed that one a little bit too much
but before we get to any of that guys i
want to talk to you about relief man you
know is biden's botched afghanistan exit
making you nauseous i can tell you
catching up on it in 24 hours it's quite
nauseating are you feeling queasy on
your commute right now all the trains
subways and bumper-to-bumper traffic
making you sick to your stomach we've
all experienced that horrible feeling
whether it's in the back seat of a car
staring at your phone maybe after one
too many on a night out with friends or
even just from the anxiety of a long
work day nausea can ruin a day force us
to change our plans and in the most
severe cases it can make you unable to
function for those of you who can relate
i've got good news you've got to check
out relief band relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is a hundred percent drug free
non-drowsy and provides all-natural
relief with zero side effects for as
long as needed how it works is relief
man stimulates a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to relieve
nausea for patients but now through
relief band it's available to the masses
anyone who deals with nausea knows how
awful it is even if you don't get
nauseous often relief man is worth
trying for the anxiety benefits alone
this is not a product that you want to
miss out on it'll bring you peace of
mind and help you not worry about nausea
again as the world is opening back up
may we pray don't let the fear of nausea
keep you on the sidelines and if you're
gonna get ready to take that summer road
trip hopping on a boat or you're just
anxious about heading back into the
office i've got good news right now
relief band has an exclusive offer just
for my audience if you go to
reliefband.com
and use promo code ruben you'll receive
20 off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com
slash reuben or use promo code ruben for
20 off plus free shipping and now back
to me
trust me people getting back on the grid
can make you nauseous okay uh all right
so look the main
thing that i'm going to devote my time
and my life and my energies and probably
this show too over the next 13 or so
days is the recall of gavin newsom he is
an evil disney cartoon villain who has
wrecked california with homelessness and
high taxes and high regulation and
everything is expensive and businesses
are closed and he is the worst sort of
elitist
lefty i'm going to send my kids to
private school that'll be open without
masks while i close your schools and my
son is going to go to basketball camp
without masks while we keep your kids at
home and just all of the ridiculous
hypocrisy and the lying that we are all
used to it is all summed up in that
overly slicked back head of hair that is
gavin newsom okay he's just terrible we
know that well it's not just that you've
got a terrible candidate we actually
have a man who is good who is decent who
is a lifelong
californian born in los angeles who has
been fighting for the right things for a
long time and if you care about identity
politics i don't he happens to be black
and you'd think that the media would be
very excited that a black man is now
making some serious headway in the race
for governor here in california but no
that's not what the media is doing not
even at the los angeles times so this
was a headline from just in the last
couple days at the los angeles times the
liberal los angeles times which is
always looking out for the minorities
right
larry elder is the black face of white
supremacy
you've been warned okay this was a piece
in the los angeles times now i just want
to be very clear larry elder is not a
white supremacist there is far more
evidence that whoever wrote this piece
and the person who cleared this piece
that they are probably white
supremacists than larry elder being a
white supremacist larry elder wants
everyone treated equally larry elder
cares about facts he cares
that all people will be treated the same
under the law
he has done research i mean this is a
guy he is he is a dictionary and an
encyclopedia of information okay that's
what larry elder is not only born
in south central l.a but but been here
as an outsider not only because of the
color of his skin and being a
conservative and he's not even a
conservative in a traditional sense of
conservative he always calls himself a
small l libertarian really which is that
he just doesn't want the government
involved in in your life or in his life
it's as simple as that but this is what
the media does
when they get somebody that they're
scared of all they can do is lie about
them and it's just it's just so twisted
right like i don't have to belabor the
point you get it that he's not a white
supremacist obviously and i assure you
google it yourself spend the rest of the
day googling or duck duck going whatever
you do and you are not going to find
literally any statements of gavin of
larry elder saying anything to the
effect that would be construed as white
supremacy okay so that's that's just
number one the la times is just
ridiculous and by the way i would also
say that this is actually a good sign
because when these type of hit pieces
start coming out that means that they
know that larry elder is a threat so
when i was actually at this dinner about
uh 12 days or so ago with larry elder he
was talking about some of the hit pieces
and that cnn started talking about his
campaign and a few other things and i
said to him i said that's the best sign
it doesn't matter if they're all hit
pieces that means they now see you as a
threat and they can't ignore you any
longer right because they should have
been talking about the recall for months
and months right like it doesn't matter
whether you're for the recall or against
the recall the idea that
roughly 1.7 million californians hand
signed a recall
is extraordinary the fact that this
thing's happening is an extraordinary uh
moment for america right because if we
can fix california maybe we can actually
fix the country you know as i always say
i'm a dreamer but i'm not the only one
so anyway they're they're worried that
larry is the real deal and he is the
real deal and then check out what
happened yesterday so let's pull up the
video so yesterday before you click play
on this let's just hold that screenshot
there for a second if we could uh so uh
no let's let's put up the twitter feed
for a second
so larry tweeted this out so we're going
to show you the larry so that's larry's
tweet now this is my twitter feed okay
so i did a screen grab a video screen
grab of my twitter feed so larry tweeted
out this video about gavin newsom so i
clicked it now let's just click play
it's about a 20 second video here you're
watching what happened on my phone so on
my phone i suddenly was given a warning
about this video about this video about
gavin newsom now we're just going to
keep playing here so i had to cancel or
confirm that this video was
inappropriate or offensive and then once
i did that i was given another warning
and then i was able to watch the video
so you'll see just uh you know about
three or four everybody outside this
state
is bitching about this state
okay now that's
extremely interesting okay
a candidate for governor of california
tweets out a video about his opponent
and two pop-ups are shown on youtube now
the first one is the particularly
interesting one let's pull it up again
what they say right there is the
following content has been identified by
the youtube community as inappropriate
or offensive to some audiences now i
don't know who the youtube community is
i don't know how they decide what is
inappropriate or offensive but now
here's what's fascinating about this
they give you two options there you can
confirm it or cancel it so first i
clicked cancel because i don't agree
with that so i clicked cancel meaning i
could just then watch the video i don't
agree that it's whatever i was about to
watch is going to be offensive or
anything like that when i clicked cancel
it doesn't let you go to the video
anymore it just takes you to the youtube
home page so then i did it again i
clicked confirm but the word confirm
there am i confirming
thus that it is uh inappropriate or
offensive it sounds like i am like i'm
giving more credence to the idea that
this anti-gavin newsom ad is somehow
offensive or something like that and
then there's this secondary pop-up now
it doesn't matter what's in that video
and i you we have the title there so you
can go check out that video yourself it
is irrelevant it is fairly obvious that
youtube does not want you to see
videos that are against gavin newsom by
the way i've had a whole bunch of you
before i went off the grid a whole bunch
of you were telling me that often when
gavin newsom tweets something if you
tweet something auntie gavin newsom back
at him that your tweets get pushed down
in his timeline i have no doubt that any
of this stuff is true right we all know
this right like this is sort of the
nauseating part uh which is sort of very
obvious to me at the moment um related
to big tech it's like we all know all
the crap is happening and it keeps
happening and we have to talk about it
and yet at the same time it just keeps
happening so so it's sort of a problem
there anyway why do i think this is
interesting because big tech is
basically saying we're running cover for
gavin newsom but now i've got something
even more interesting than that so i
didn't watch tv or any of that stuff
when i was off the grid but i was
watching some old basketball videos on
youtube and a couple anti-larry elder
ads kept popping up and very pro-gavin
newsom ads kept popping up so we're
going to show you one of the ads i was
able to find one of them and then we're
going to tell you who it was paid for
and then i think you're going to start
seeing what what i'm doing here take a
look what's at stake in the september
14th recall it's a matter of life and
death with delta surging gavin newsom is
protecting california requiring
vaccination for health workers and
school employees the top republican
candidate he peddled deadly conspiracy
theories and would eliminate vaccine
mandates on day one threatening school
closures and our recovery
stop the spread return your ballot or
vote in person by september 14th
protect california by voting no on the
republican recall
okay so let's just be very clear what's
going on here that ad and i saw at least
two others and i suspect there were
others uh which was saying that it's a
life or death situation whether you vote
for gavin newsom or not uh delta is
surging now if delta is surging and it's
a life or death situation why would you
want to keep the guy in who it's surging
under right so maybe it was secretly a
larry elderhead but what i thought was
more interesting about this is what you
get at the end of that ad where it tells
you it's paid for
by reed hastings and i was looking at it
and i was going that name does ring a
bell it turns out that reed hastings is
the ceo
of netflix
well you're not going to believe this
guys not only is he paying for all of
these ads on youtube uh that are lies i
mean there there's another video where
he basically implies that larry elder of
course is a white supremacist and it's
just filled with endless lies okay like
oh it's life or death yes larry elder
wants to kill your kids but then we
started doing a little more research and
we've got some info here from politico
netflix founder and co-ceo reid hastings
is spending three million dollars to
shield governor gavin newsom from a
recall vote in a demonstration of the
enormous sums newsome's allies could
marshal in his defense according to a
state filing under california rules
newsom can raise unlimited sums to fend
off a recall effort that will likely
land before voters in the fall while
other gubernatorial candidates are
subject to campaign limits of 32 400 per
election in their direct accounts while
hastings millions represent the largest
single donation to date newsom has also
drawn six-figure outlays from a range of
prominent individuals in industries that
include agricultural power couple
steward and linda resnick 49ers ceo jed
york law firms and labor unions so what
is seriously interesting about this is
the ceo of netflix not only has he given
gavin 3 million he's funding all of
these ads that are all lies and then at
the same time youtube is censoring
videos about gavin newsom now i wish we
had journalists i know we don't have
journalists that was the extent of my
journalism right there i just gave you a
couple pieces of a puzzle but do you
think it's possible that youtube's going
oh we get money
from netflix ceo reed hastings and i'm
guessing that the youtube people are
probably close to the netflix people
they're like oh we're getting all this
money from this guy we like avenues and
we don't like scary larry elder so not
only are we going to take ads to put on
all of these videos we're also going to
block certain content by making you
click a couple times and imply that
things are offensive when they're not
and inappropriate when they're not and
everything else do you think there might
be some sort of collusion there if
you're if you know of a journalist could
you send them this uh if anyone knows of
journalists and i know that there just
aren't any i'm asking for a union
unicorn you know it's like are there any
unicorns available somebody get me a
unicorn anyway i thought that was worth
uh mentioning uh but now guys i want to
talk to you about ladder and then we're
going to get
to the q a which i will do as fast as
possible because we had a zillion
questions in there but first on ladder
guys i want to talk for a minute about
things that have fundamentally changed
the way we live these are the disruptors
things like smartphones streaming
services whiter than white paint that
actually cools down buildings or dogs
named clyde who like to jump on you each
time you come home another disrupter i
heard of recently is a company called
ladder who basically took the life
insurance industry flipped it upside
down and shook out the inefficiencies
which sounds a lot like clyde actually
before ladder if you wanted to get life
insurance you had to drive across town
sit through a sales pitch fill out a ton
of paperwork and then wait six to eight
weeks to find out if you've been
approved you'd also receive a zillion
phone calls from agents trying to bundle
your life insurance with things like car
insurance now with ladder you can get
fast affordable term life insurance
without leaving home it's 100 digital
when you apply for 3 million or less in
coverage no doctors no needles no
paperwork so if you're between the ages
of 20 to 60 need coverage and want to
team up with a company that's redeeming
life insurance choose ladder the process
is super quick and easy go to
ladderlife.com today's ladderlife.com
ruben today to see if you're instantly
approved that's
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.comrubin
ladderlife.com slash reuben and now back
to me okay guys so anyway
electeelder.com and vote yes on the
recall september 14th 2021 this is our
chance it's the last chance it really is
okay
uh let's move you know let's skip that
first question i want to address that a
little bit later in the week probably or
probably next week um let's go to ben
here uh first welcome back to hell
second what was more surprising upon
jumping back into the matrix the fact
that andrew cuomo actually resigned or
that joe biden's withdrawal from
afghanistan is so shockingly bad that
almost no one in the corporate media was
willing to cover for him at first okay
so let me just quickly address the cuomo
thing i am genuinely shocked like my if
you watched the video yesterday
that was genuine shock on my face my
feeling was that the ship had sort of
sailed like they had decided that the
you know putting all of the old people
the elderly people back in the old age
homes and then all of those people dying
of covid they had sort of just let that
go the fed said they weren't going to
investigate any of it and then this sort
of like oh another girl said another
thing about him and he patted someone on
the butt and he touched someone on the
back of the head and he kissed someone
on the forehead and all of these things
it just felt like it was adding up to
nothing and also it was the summer so
like things start getting lost in the
summer people stopped paying attention
so i'm shocked that somehow
this didn't seem like a serious smoking
gun like there was evidence that he
really raped somebody or anything else
like that i'll also repeat what i said
yesterday to corolla which is you know i
don't revel in the destruction of people
um if he did anything bad and it sounds
like he did then he has to deal with the
consequences of it but the idea that
we're just going to destroy all of our
public figures one at a time and it's
not just our public figures that all of
our histories will be on earth and that
the mob and cancel culture will just
come for everybody that is not great
that being said i don't think andrew
cuomo is a particularly good person i
think he thought he was sort of king of
new york as opposed to an elected
official
and you know this is what
the left has wrought on america you're
going to run around calling all of us
racists and we're sexists and we're
bigots and we hate gay people and all of
this nonsense and eventually it is going
to turn on you guys so they're just
turning their guns on one of their own
uh for those of those that are really
excited about him being gone you know
it's like all right well we'll see what
this lieutenant governor does and you
know does new york probably just go
further left yeah because the left has a
way of just dragging everybody into the
sarlacc pit so we'll see about that as
for the afghanistan stuff
we're trying to get glenn beck on the
show for tomorrow to give me sort of a
full recap he has done some incredible
work
lifting people out of afghanistan how
much money roughly did he raise
he raised millions of dollars we're
gonna try to get some info on this real
quick uh just in the last like two weeks
basically since this whole thing
happened uh to get people out of
afghanistan he's been doing some
incredible coverage i watched a bunch of
his videos yesterday because i'm really
trying to catch up on this on the fly
and i have to say it's it's really sort
of incredible to catch up on a story
that has so many moving parts in just a
day because it's i have to piece
together like how the media narrative
was shifting the entire time as i'm
putting it together glenn beck raised 20
million dollars in three days to help
people get out of afghanistan it was
mostly persecuted christians 20 million
dollars in afghanistan i'm so thrilled
and honored to call glenn a friend and
and you know be in business with him
with our our deal with the blaze and
he's just such a good
human being uh so hopefully we can get
him tomorrow we'll we'll unpack a little
bit more about afghanistan but i have to
say although i'm surprised at the level
of the disaster and those videos and the
people falling off the plane and now
they have all these weapons and and
helicopters and all of this stuff and
that we abandoned the the translators
like it's so horrible on every possible
level and our troops that were killed
in a certain way i'm not surprised
because in a certain way it's like what
did you guys expect the president of the
united states obviously has dementia and
that's not even part of this really this
administration is terrible it is
horrible every bad thing that can happen
will happen because the media will cover
for them and in some weird ways this
almost feels and maybe this is me just
being off the grid so i'm seeing it all
at once but it's like it's all so
ridiculously horrible first off they've
been trying to impeach trump over this
for without question right um but it's
so horrible the way we left and it's so
embarrassing to the united states that
it almost feels like it's intentional
like i don't think these guys really
like the united states i don't know that
joe biden knows what he likes but
whoever's pulling his strings and then
you know my feelings about most of the
progressives at this point like they're
kind of happy that whether we're in
there or out of there that it's just
this just looks awful for the united
states there are very few people looking
at the united states right now between
our president this withdrawal and the
disaster uh and going boy the united
states that's a that's a place that has
its [ __ ] together right like this is not
good for the united states at all and
all that being said you can find plenty
of videos of me over the past 10 years
saying that we shouldn't even be in
afghanistan and it was our longest war
over 20 years
at war we didn't even know why we were
there
but you know if you break it do you have
to fix it and how do you pull out of
these things and maybe it's always going
to be messy
but this is an unmitigated like
extraordinary disaster so hope so
obviously we'll be covering more of it
uh over the next couple weeks but
hopefully we can get glenn tomorrow to
discuss that uh kelly says how do we
stop the democrats from placing all of
these refugees into states that
democrats have been trying to win for a
long time and haven't yet are the states
able to sue the federal government to
stop this so this is really interesting
uh tucker carlson's been talking a lot
about this um well he's been talking
about it for for months but he even
mentioned on his show last night i was
actually on tucker uh last night in case
you guys uh didn't see it we put a clip
up on the uh on the twitter machine not
that i want to send anyone over to
twitter but i was on tucker last night
but this idea that we're taking in all
of these people mostly from mexico but
you know they get to mexico from all
these other countries it's unclear if
they're migrants or if they're really
under threat or whatever and it seems
like it's an awful lot of able-bodied
men in their 20s and not a lot of you
know older women or young children but
all of these people are now seemingly
being sent all over to these different
states and your question there basically
is what can the states do if they don't
want these people now i have
some degree of sympathy as we all do for
anyone that's truly fleeing
tyranny most of us in the united states
our ancestors whoever came here before
us came from something pretty terrible
right we all we all know that story we
all know what's on the statue of liberty
right the huddled masses the tired and
the poor um but because i think this
administration is so deeply corrupt and
because they have said you don't have to
have ids to vote well then just
funneling in more people and then having
the government give them things so
they're ever dependent on the government
so they'll always vote for those people
while at the same time they'll tell you
the other people think you're racist and
they're evil and this whole system is
evil
you could see what a toxic really
dangerous situation they're putting us
in i don't know exactly it's a great
question what can the states do um i
would imagine that most of the red
states particularly abbot in texas has
got to be looking into because he's a
border state obviously not the only one
but it seems like a lot of people are
coming through texas what can we do to
make sure they're not settling people
here but
once they send people to all these other
places well then what happens if
eventually they just start flipping
people like is that is that a grand
conspiracy theory to think that if you
let a whole bunch of people in you give
them a whole bunch of stuff that they're
gonna vote for you like is that a grand
conspiracy theory does that have
anything to do with being a white
supremacist every time they talk uh
tucker talks about this they imply that
he's a white supremacist for talking
about why you can't just have your
country flooded with refugees or
immigrants and by the way every european
country knows this is which is why
angela merkel in germany after they let
in a million or so people said it was a
mistake and why most of the eastern
european countries like poland have
basically closed their borders because
it's up to you and i would say this for
every single country on earth not just
for the united states we have to figure
out not only what our borders are we
fortunately know what they are but how
to protect them and who can come into
our country and and also if we're so
evil and we're so patriarchal and we're
so racist that there's so many white
supremacists that we're all so mean why
come
go to sweden
isn't that what they always tell us
sweden's the best place on earth
clyde says what was your favorite part
about being off the grid so you know i
didn't even really talk about it that
much sort of
the the true off the grid part yeah we
ate good food and we listened to a lot
of music and we took walks and we just i
just really had an incredible
month like just from the eaton right and
the working out and we didn't really see
people david was really the only one
that i talked to talked to clyde a
little bit and this question's from
someone named clyde how about that
but my favorite part probably i'll give
you a little insider info didn't wear
underwear for most of the month a lot of
free balling yeah it's the summer here
in la uh david got me these lululemon
shorts couple pairs of lululemon there's
uh there's no nothing in there it's not
quite a bathing suit but it's not quite
a short and i was free balling for most
of the month and i and i got to tell you
i felt free i felt like myself not only
that but i didn't really do my hair all
month
i got a couple headbands i usually wear
a hat but about halfway through david's
like why are you always wearing a hat
it's hot out why do you have this big
hat on
so i started headbanding it and uh so i
was wandering around usually in like you
know cut off shirt and free balling
ballin
light shorts and a headband and i just
you know wasn't you know although this
is another nice new jacket i told you i
guess got a couple new shirts and new
jackets but it was just nice to like
just kind of be it really was just
and really of course the thing about the
phone like never thinking about the
phone or or also like i'll tell you this
the first like two weeks of going off
and i told you yesterday we went right
to this rainforest thing in in mexico it
was awesome like my dreams were amazing
truly because if you're not thinking
about politics or the news or just
whatever stresses you have in life as
you go to bed and just kind of letting
it be
i don't know your mind has a way of
reorganizing itself and and
it was just it was just perfect actually
in this rainforest we stayed at um you
know it's rainy season in mexico right
now at least in western mexico and there
were incredible thunder and lightning
storms every night so basically every
night we would just be looking out a
window over the ocean with just awesome
lightning storms like there were nights
where i was like that's god like you see
this lightning with the clouds and like
it was just everything about it was was
just great and i guess that it gives me
enough energy to come back here and
hopefully
uh feel clear and clean enough to to be
worthy of you viewing what we do here
phillip says when larry elder wins the
recall election i like the way you think
phil are you going to petition him to
make the reuben including the corrected
spelling the official state sandwich i
love it yes the reuben will be the
official state sandwich of california
that'll really stick it to newsom
that would be fantastic i will talk to
larry elder about that rhiannon says
have you heard the exact timeline of how
we left afghanistan if so what are your
thoughts so i'll address this a little
bit more tomorrow if we can get glenn on
and if not for tomorrow uh we'll do
plenty on this next week but i have been
trying to piece together the whole
timeline
you know adam obviously yesterday adam
corolla was trying to give me a lot of
information at once so i've watched a
couple videos on it i watched some ben
shapiro videos i watched some glenn
videos as i said actually if you have
some videos that you think are really
great
sort of fair honest clean clear recaps
of what happened in afghanistan i would
love to see them uh because i'm trying
to catch up on the flight my guys have
been sending me stuff as well uh the
best way to get it to me is
reubenreport.locals.com just post it in
the feed and i'll take a look uh kathy
says how are you younger looking now
than your first rather life-changing
interview with larry elder sincere
question how to put on well first off at
the moment i mean i i really as i said i
took care of myself really and i do a
generally good job
with that as is and and david's a great
chef so we eat right and
i try to exercise and all that stuff um
but you know part of the answer is that
when i did that original interview with
larry elder can we get the date on that
i think it was um
i guess it was about march of 2016 if
i'm not mistaken
so it's it's about five years ago i
think a little more than five years ago
that original interview with larry
that's when i was in the midst of
dealing with that alopecia areata that i
developed which i've told you about and
i wrote about in the book where i had
lost
probably about 40 of my hair it was it's
stress related your white blood cells
basically attack your hair follicles i
was on this really awful experimental
medication if you watch that video i'm
kind of bloated in the face i have big
bags under my eyes that first prageru
video that i did why i left the left you
can see it in my face there it was
january 2016. um so over over five years
ago um and you know because of that the
medication was awful the you know
obviously losing my hair it was all
terrible i really started doing things
better i started you know eating better
less sugar less carbs things like that
um and i think i just have a better
handle on my life you know that again is
partly why i do the off the grid thing
as i sit here at this moment
you know i'm in a pretty good groove at
the moment i feel physically good i feel
mentally good i feel spiritually good
and
i think those things kind of shine we we
all go through that right like when
you're when you're kind of living the
life that you're supposed to be living
doing what you're supposed to be doing
like you can sort of see it jordan
peterson actually talks about this quite
a bit that when you see somebody
that's living the life they're supposed
to be doing
and and supposed to be living like you
can actually kind of see it in their
face so i appreciate the compliment and
uh and i hope if i start looking all
bloated and depressed the big bags under
my eyes and everything else that uh
you'll call me out on it because it
means that probably something something
else ain't right uh kevin says is there
any hope of the american people being
able to hold our own government
accountable for their actions
will there be any legal consequences to
the afghanistan withdrawal kovid being
released to the world or the flat out
lies to our own government uh that our
own government feeds us daily you know
what's interesting about that question
on the covert front i actually don't
know the answer to this but has there
been any other talk about the lab leak
or anything else in the last month like
have we have we officially decided it's
a lab leak or not i guess i should
probably know that um i assume that most
people are saying okay so michael's
telling me right now the the republicans
are saying yes stems are saying let's
wait and find out or who knows something
to that effect okay and that's even part
of the problem right there it's like
let's let's just say that there's
evidence that it was a lab leak like
true like like locked evidence it's like
only half the people are going to
believe it anyway and let's say there
was evidence that it wasn't a lively
lab leak only half the people are going
to believe it so that gets us to that
reality war that i'm always talking
about as for holding anybody accountable
or the lies it's like
i don't know trust me i thought a lot
about this
over the month of like how i can do this
show and still
feel like i'm accomplishing something
when so much of what i do is just oh
this person who is supposed to be
trusted as a journalist or as a
politician is just lying like so much of
what we do here
is just correcting lies but i don't
think that is enough and i spent a lot
of time thinking about how we're going
to do this show going forward and i
actually do have some ideas and i think
you'll see some shifts in the way we
cover some of these stories because i
don't want to spend every day reacting
right this is why like i like to build
things it's like what i've done with
locals i didn't want to just talk about
oh big tech sucks i wanted to actually
build something to fight it and i want
to help build a structure so that we'll
know that they're liars and and that's
what i meant when i said yesterday that
you know maybe what this all will lead
to in america the the endless lying
the big tech manipulation all this stuff
is that we will sort of have a cold
civil war i don't want anyone fighting
anybody i don't want you know what i
mean or any and i don't want the country
to break up or any of those things but
in a way we are in a cold civil war
whether we like it or not like if we
have a set of people
that will lie to
endlessly attain more and more power
versus set of people that want to be
left alone like what is that there's not
a lot of negotiation there there's not a
lot of room to come together so what i
want to do is is further
your ability to to live on your own
terms with people that you want to live
around and actually that's very much
what my next book is about uh okay let's
see perry says why don't we ever see
what actual hospitalizations of actual
covid patients and open bed counts for
hospitals that seems to be a more
important stat than just the number of
cases out in the wild we will be living
with covid forever so we are going to
need to learn to coexist with it i
wonder what motivation hospitals have
for reporting accurately you know uh
corolla actually addressed this a little
bit yesterday talking about dr drew how
he's referenced some of this stuff that
when you get numbers out of hospitals
you really have to dive deeper into the
numbers relative to obesity and age and
how many people are dying and what i
would still bring this back to
but i would still bring this back to
is how is it as far as i know but
correct me if i'm wrong that in all of
the world there were no hospitals that
absolutely collapsed right i'm not even
talking in the western world was there
anywhere in an undeveloped country that
hospitals absolutely collapsed that we
found out that places that little
villages somewhere in africa where
people couldn't socially distance or
didn't know what to do or didn't have
access to masks or clean water or
something
that villages didn't collapse that no
country really fell apart like
i think we're allowed to ask these
questions and that is not to deny that
kovid is real um by the way i have i
mentioned uh i think i mentioned this
yesterday with adam i got a little
update on it actually this morning i
have a friend who's in the health care
field here in los angeles who i
completely trust who a few weeks or i
guess it was right before we went off
the grid had told me that he knew nine
people
in la who currently had kovid
and they were all vaccinated and he
didn't know any people that weren't
vaccinated that had coveted he just
contacted me yesterday
he told me that since then in the months
since then 30 people
30 people that were vaccinated he knows
that have had covid since then i know
and one person who was unvaccinated
okay i'm just telling you something that
i'm hearing are we allowed to still talk
about that sort of thing
so yes we need to figure out a way to
dive into these numbers but again i
would say at this point all of the
things related to kovid have more to do
with governmental power and and some way
that we are being manipulated that we
don't fully understand who is doing
exactly who's doing it exactly or why
they are doing it i am much more
concerned about that
than the disease of kovid and just one
other quick thing on this which is that
i guess yesterday morning or was it this
morning actually that rogen and covid
was that this morning or yesterday it
was yesterday uh joe rogan has announced
that he has covid and he's taking some
experimental stuff it's unclear i don't
think he was vaccinated he had said on
his show that you know he didn't feel
that young people should be vaccinated
but there was a certain glee in
mainstream media of ha ha anti-vaxx joe
rogan got coveted and it's like oh are
you rooting for people to die by the way
i'm going to guess that joe rogan's not
going to die of kovid and that he's
going to probably be just fine but again
you have to do what you think is right
for yourself but when i talk about sort
of this this um
this soft cold war or us just kind of
going in different directions as a
country i see no way around it there's
going to be some people that are always
going to be want to want to be masked
forever that are going to want things to
be closed down forever that are always
going to want to point to other people
and say you're the diseased ones and
you're doing this to all of us and we
need more rules because of you and then
there's going to be this other set of
people that are going to say we just
want to try to continue life the way we
want to live it
i'm into those people and that's that's
again where i want to spend my energy uh
jenna says i'm so curious about your off
the grid and clyde who watches him and
did he freak out in excitement when you
guys got back so for the first half of
it i had my buddy john and his
girlfriend christina who i hope are
watching right now you better be i flew
them in from jersey and they stayed here
for about two weeks and they took great
care of the house thanks for not killing
the plants guys and uh they took care of
clyde and clyde looks like a million
bucks when we got back he was like a
little leaner a little more muscular so
i think john was running around uh and
then david's sister came for the second
two weeks uh yes he was super psyched to
see us and uh you know he's now he's
almost two and a half years old now it's
it's kind of crazy we got him at the
beginning of lockdown which was a year
and a half ago we got him during two
weeks to flatten the curve remember that
that remember that thing that's when we
got clyde he was but a mere pup but he's
he's sort of shifted now into that two
two and a half year
age where they start calming down a
little bit but he's still a boxer and
when i open the door he always jumps up
and boxers you know they're called
boxers because they kind of punch when
they're jumping and he has punched me in
the nuts more times than i'd like to
admit which by the way if you're not
wearing underwear it doesn't have
anything to soften the blow he also
punched bob saget once in the nuts when
bob came over and knocked bob to the
floor little uh little inside info for
you all right what else we got here
that's it give me one more one more for
the good people
give me one more
let's see how about the one before that
there we go here we go april says what
are you looking forward to most for the
new reuben report season
you know i think i've been sort of
addressing it throughout this
which is that a this this idea that i'm
going to do my best to keep you sane
because you keep me sane and it is only
the same people who are going to fix
everything that's wrong so like i'm
looking forward to figuring out
some new ways that we can do that
because i don't want to as i said
dedicate every show to aoc lied about
this again and this idiot on msnbc said
that and everything else what i really
want to do is i want to figure out
uh a better way a bigger way i should
say to use this platform whether it's my
show my social media accounts everything
that we're building at locals
to empower you guys in a better way so
that if you have a business i want to be
able to help your businesses i want to
be able to
if you're struggling with something
we've had a couple instances of this
where someone in the reuben report
community was struggling with something
we were able to raise funds for people
or
but it's not just about money or
business like i want to just find the
same
people and i want to strengthen them and
i want to help find ways that we can be
less reliant on the government and these
big systems that are just simply not
working
like if you're just sitting around right
now thinking that oh this thing is
working the old world is going to come
back and joe biden cares about you and
the cdc cares about you and they've got
your best interests out out for you and
all that stuff it's like you're missing
you're missing the bigger picture now i
don't know that we can fix the whole
system like something something seems
really wrong right like i think we all
know that like if you're watching this
at this point you know something ain't
right well i don't know that we can fix
the whole system but i think there are
things we can do for our selves whether
it's growing some food knowing how to
cook encouraging each other to
be in better shape
like whatever it might be if we can
figure out those community things that
used to be
local like in your village on your
street things i think if we can return
to that more that's how we'll fix this
thing from the from the bottom up it
ain't coming from the top down that's
really where i'm gonna focus my energies
and i am excited to be back i gotta tell
you the last 24 hours have been a little
weird because i really had such a great
month as i said i i had i don't know
that anyone in this country had a better
month than i did it was it was just
perfect there were so many nights that
uh you know we put our heads on the
pillow and i would turn to david and say
we just had a great day today was a
great day well i'm back doing what i
love this is what i love it ain't just
relaxing and enjoying myself but this is
what i love and i hope that it brings
you some value and if it doesn't there's
probably some other youtube i assume
there's other shows on youtube there are
a couple other shows on youtube you can
watch those all right guys reminder you
can watch my entire return to the grid
with guest host adam carolla it's up on
youtube right now and of course it's
also on
reubenreport.locals.com and we've got a
ton of stuff going on with locals you
know i i teased out some stuff we've
partnered with rumble on a couple things
there's a lot happening there and if you
want to interact with me i just i just
can't interact on other social media
with people anymore like it just
especially after coming back off the
grid like to dive i open up twitter it's
just like all these crazy people
fighting with each other and anime
avatars fighting with uh you know
professors over string theory it's all
bananas but if you want to communicate
directly with me you want to share some
music and some exercise routines or just
whatever you love doing
reubenreport.locals.com all right we're
back tomorrow hopefully with glenn beck
and we'll do a special on what's going
on in afghanistan uh it sounds like
glenn might be traveling though so if
that doesn't happen we'll figure out
something else and yeah we'll cover more
of that next week i thank you for
watching it's good to be back everybody
and we'll see you tomorrow